ich persönlich bin ja ein riesiger Apple
Fan
das hier ist meine Lieblingssorte aber
auch als naturtrübe Apfelsaft finde ich
echt klasse
endlich mal zum Thema des heutigen
Videos meine lieben Freunde das neue
iPhone
das juckt eigentlich auch nicht so doll
jedes Jahr im September stellt Apple
sein neues iPhone vor früher haben die
noch so krasse Events gemacht wo dann
voll viele Leute Presse etc eingeladen
war aber seit Corona machen die das
meistens online mit irgendwelchen Videos
oder Livestreams und das haben sie auch
jetzt gemacht
[Musik]
anscheinend das Büro von denen
es sieht halt quasi aus wie ein
Sportplatz ne also wenn ich das mit
unseren deutschen Büros Vergleiche ne
halten wir uns allerdings nicht so lange
an deren Sportplatz da auf denn dann
ging es los und man wird begrüßt
guten Morgen also wirklich ne aber deine
Beine ich habe noch nie solche Opern
gesehen zum Coca hat dann auf jeden Fall
nur kurz etwas gesagt weil dann die
Personen die sich bei Apple um die Apple
watches kümmert was erzählt hat und hat
einfach direkt angefangen zu flexen
nee also es ist for real wirklich crazy
was Apple da alles auf die Beine
gestellt hat die letzten Jahre vor allem
mit der Apple watch einfach komplett am
rasieren gewesen das Ding ist ja durch
die Decke gegangen wie keine Ahnung was
apropos durch die Decke gehen
ihr checkt den Job jetzt
[Musik]
war witzig weil ich habe gesagt durch
die Decke gehen und dann ist der
Übergang was ich wirklich crazy finde
ist dass dieses ganze Apple Headquarter
Büro da hinten in San Francisco wirklich
von oben aussieht wie ein Sportplatz
aber von unten einfach aussieht wie eine
Luxus top Villa Designerhaus
ich habe absolut gar kein Wort von dem
verstanden was diese Dame da gerade
gesagt hat aber es sieht einfach aus wie
eine Luxusvilla in Los Angeles Arena
kommt dann haben sie allerdings ein paar
Funktionen der neuen Apple watch
vorgestellt und zwar kann jetzt die
Temperatur messen
über die Haut
Display und wofür das auch noch extrem
krass gut geeignet ist ist der
periodenzyklus ich hatte nicht
Sexualkunde aber da kann eine Frau
irgendwie sehen ob Sie
schwanger werden könnte wenn Sie das
wenn
alle respective
genau ja das ist wirklich verrückt weil
du kannst damit halt einfach theoretisch
deine Apple watch als Verhütungsmittel
benutzen weil du genau siehst okay
könnte ich überhaupt gerade schwanger
werden oder nicht was aber auch noch
extrem crazy ist ist dass die Apple
watch jetzt ein emergency
calling
series
das heißt diese Uhr merkt wenn du einen
Unfall hattest und kontaktiert dann
automatisch deine notfallkontakte und
ruf den Notdienst an
working
aber warum steht jetzt auf dem Berg der
hat ja gerade schon gesagt dass die an
etwas komplett neuem
gearbeitet haben
Apple watch ultra
die ist irgendwie noch krasser und wird
auch vorgestellt wie ein Transformer
die Apple watch ultra kann quasi alles
was die normale Apple watch auch kann
nur ein bisschen besser also keine
Ahnung gefühlt kannst du dir aus dem
Flugzeug runterschmeißen auf dem Asphalt
und die geht nicht kaputt so mäßig und
die bewerben diese Apple watch auch
immer mit zu Extremsportarten ne
[Musik]
ich
will mich jetzt nicht so weit aus dem
Fenster legen aber ich würde sagen
99,9999999999999% der Menschen hier an
der watch kaufen nutzen sie nicht um
irgendwelche Wüsten entlang zu rennen
auf irgendwelche Berge zu klettern oder
40.000 km in der Tiefsee rum zu
schnorcheln warum
allerdings den ganzen Uhren Apple watch
scheiß da mal beiseite und schauen uns
die neuen airpods an die mit einem super
coolen
Tanz beworben wurden
[Musik]
allerdings habe ich ja bereits im Titel
eingeblendet gesehen meine lieben
Freunde es soll heute natürlich nicht
nur um die neue Apple watch oder die
neuen airpods gehen sondern auch um das
[Musik]
sieht genauso aus
wie das jetzige
Nachname dann Pfeffer
im Kalender meiner Produktvorstellung
ist es ja dann eigentlich immer so dass
die wichtigsten für das Unternehmen am
stolzesten neuen Funktionen des Produkts
als erstes auch vorgestellt werden
schauen wir mal was das hier beinhaltet
iPhone
und hier war ich schon raus meine lieben
Freunde denn das ist der größte Cap den
ich je gehört habe mein kack Handy hält
vielleicht maximal eine Stunde maximal
das Scheißding der Akku wird schlechter
von Tag zu Tag all the battery life in
dein Arsch
cayennek with core GPU
genau
wollen wir auch alle tagtäglich solche
Bilder mit unserem Handy machen in
unserer kleinen hawaiianischen Bucht im
Vorgarten 95% der Sache in meiner
Galerie sind einfach Screenshots
Bildschirmfotos irgendwelche dummen
selfies also kommen wir nicht mit der
blöden Kamera da die jedes Jahr um zwei
Dezibel Megapixel in seinen 11:15 Uhr
irgendwelche relevanten Neuigkeiten
real time connectivity
ich wohne in Deutschland
ich bin froh wenn ich Edge stellt habe
und die Kombi mit 5g um die Ecke
und zu guter Letzt wurden dann auf jeden
Fall auch noch mal die Preise
vorgestellt
und die will ich euch natürlich auch
nicht vorenthalten
das neue iPhone 14 pro
kostet über 200 Euro mehr als das iPhone
13 pro
und es kann nichts mehr
absolut gar nix von daher kriegt Apple
dieses Jahr auf jeden Fall kein Geld von
mir in ihre Täsch reingesteckt ich
verzichte auf das iPhone 14 ich bleib
beim iPhone 13 ich sag's euch das Ding
ist für die Tonne genau wie mein Content
wenn es euch trotzdem gefallen hat dann
lasst gerne einen Daumen hoch und dann
Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen ich fresse jetzt
Klopapier